is it possible that Trump is convicted
of or pleads guilty to something but
ends up with only a symbolic sentence uh
maybe even a suspended sentence or home
confinement we're talking about a former
president here and all of those
circumstances are 100 possibilities if
you think about the totality the
seriousness of the crimes in the Federal
indictment the possibility of trump
facing three or four different
indictments it sort of feels like that
could very likely point to some prison
time at the same time we're talking
about a former president nearly 80 years
old with a lot of at least plausible
mitigating circumstances his lawyers
could argue including age and security
issues with Trump serving even a single
day and so we may end up with some
symbolic home confinement